السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اسعد
الله مساءكم بكل خير الهام
صامت في البدايه قبل ان تسمعون صوتي الان
مبحوح شوي اصبت قبل ثلاث ايام باعراض
البرد وكاد اليوم خشيت انه يبقى معي اعراض
البرد ولا استطيع ان يتكلم وبالتالي قلت
قلب على الموجه الصامته بلغه الاشاره
وانتم عاد عيشوا الجو وتخيلوا لو الان
اتكلم بلغه الاشاره
اقول اكيد كلكم يتسائل ش قلت قلت اني
بتكلم بلغه الاشاره والحضور كلهم راح
يفكرون ايش قلت ش قاعد اقول يعني ش
الاشاره اللي قاعد اقولها تخيلوا هذا
المنظور بشكل معاكس انك تعيش في وسط يتكلم
بلغه لا تفهم ففهمها بلغه الاشاره
وبالتالي تواجه كثير من التحديات فعليا
هذا اللي يعيشه الشخص الاصم في حياته
الهام
صامت صوره تجمعني بوالدي الاصم حفظه الله
انا نشه ولد في عائله فيها اكثر من 20 اصم
تعتبر اكبر عائله في العالم العربي من
اكبر العوائل في العالم العربي فيها هذه
فيها الصمم وبالتالي اصبحت لغه الاشاره
بالنسبه لي بالنسبه لابناء عمي والسامعين
في
العائله لغه ام احنا نجيد نتق لغه الاشاره
منذ الصغر قبل ان نتقن او ننطق بكلام
مسموع وبالتالي كان هذا بالنسبه لي لما
دخلت هذا المجال اصبحت
قضيه مشيت في هذه القضيه فتره وما كنت
اعلم انه هذا
العمل سيصبح اولويه في في حياتي وفي
مسيرتي حتى وصلت الى ام ساذكرها ان شاء
الله في
العرض اللي انا اريد ان اصل اليه في هذا
العهر او هذه الكلمه البسيطه امامكم في
هذا اللقاء الملهم انه يكون عندنا قناعه
لتعلم لغه الاشاره ليش اتعلم لغه الاشاره
هذا سؤال اواجهه كثيرا في حياتي لما اقدم
دورات لغه اشاره او اتكلم انه المجتمع
لابد ان يعرف لغه الاشاره هناك اسئله
كثيره عندنا احصائيه للصم احصائيه غير
دقيقه لكن هناك احصائيه نسبه للمواليد
الفاقدين للسمع من منظمه الصحه العالميه
تقول عندنا 3% في العالم العربي ومنها دول
الخليج هم مصابين فاقدين للسمع وبالتالي
لو اخذناها على احصائيه السكان عندنا
حوالي مليون شخص فاقد للسمع يتطلب منا ان
نعرف لو ابجديات التعامل بلغه الاشاره
معهم عدد مترجم لغه
الاشاره عدد مترجم لغه الاشاره لو قلت لكم
ما يقابل هؤلاء المليون
تقريبا تصدمون المترجمين في المملكه
الرسميين على مسمى لغه اشاره مترجم لغه
اشاره هم سبعه فقط تخيل اربعه في جامعه
الملك سعود واثنين في المؤسسه العامه
لتذيب المهني واحد في وزاره العمل وصندوق
تنميه الموارد البشريه سبعه فقط اذا ما
اجملنا عدد المتطوعين او المتعاونين وهم
يشغلون وظائف اخرى وصلنا الى عدد 26 وما
زلنا بحاجه ما زلنا بحاجه تكاتف المجتمع
معنا لتعلم لغه الاشاره سيحل قضيه بالنسبه
لنا اهم ثاني لغه متداوله لغه الجسد اللغه
الصامته في العالم وبالتالي معرفتك لغه
الاشاره ستساهم بشكل مباشر انك تستفيد من
امكانياتك الجسديه مو بس عشان تتواصل مع
الصم انا لو اعطيك الان مثال اقوللك انا
جيت وقاعد اردلك قصه والله جيتك وقاعد
اقوللك واحد جا للبيت كان البيت
فاضي وكان ينوي سرقه هذا البيت وتجاوز
السور ودخل ثم ان وجد شاشه كبيره داخل
البيت واخذها ومشى الريتم هذا بس بالصوت
العادي بدون استخدام امكانيات الجسديه
وتعابير الوجه ما تعطي ذاك التاثير للقصه
لغه الاشاره هي بالضبط تحاكي كل امكانياتك
الجسديه لما اقول لك بلغه الاشاره في
حرامي كان يمشي
بصمت شاف بيت
فاضي ثم انقفل في الجدار وبدا يمشي يمشي
يمشي ودخل البيت وشاف يمين وشاف يسار وشاف
شاشه كبيره واخذها ومشى بسرعه وراح شوفوا
كيف التاثير الكبير الموجود اثناء طرح هذه
اطروحه بطريقه اخرى انت كذلك لو تتعلم لغه
الاشاره وتتحكم با امكانياتك الجسديه
وتقول والله جا واحد وراح للبيت وجا ودخل
بيت بيتنا واحنا ما كنا موجودين لكن شوف
ايش صار يقوللك ش صار بدا يمشي شوي شوي
ودخل البيت ودخل الصاله وشاف شوف حتى
تعابير الوجه تعطي تاثير في ايراد القصه
وشاف تلفزيونا في البيت وسحبه وطلع يركض
شوفوا كيف التاثير استخدام امكانياتك
الجسديه تعابير الوجه تعطي لما تتعلم لغه
الاشاره اللي احنا نعطيها كمترجمين لغه
اشاره او مدربين لغه اشاره ستطوى جسدك ان
تستخدمها حتى اثناء تعاملك مع
المجتمع لغه الاشاره ذات مكونات ثلاث كثير
منا يقول والله صعبه مش صعبه كيف لغه
الاشاره مكوناتها ثلاثه الحروف الابجديه
اللي هي الالف والباء والتاء والثاء
الحروف تستخدم في الاعلام لما اقول انا
اسمي احمد الح الاشاره الوصفيه مثلا بيت
من ايش طرق الباب شماغ احمر وصف انك ترمي
شماغ خلف راسك تشير الى احمر الى لون الفم
الترميز الترميز هي اشاره ليس لها وصف
لكنها متعارف بين الصم مثلا هذه يوم ليش
سموها يوم كذا فلها اشارات هذه المكونات
الثلاث اذا
عرفتها ستبدع وتبحر في لغه الاشاره حتى لو
ل تتقيد بالاشاره المعروفه عند الصوم في
تحدي بيني وبين نفسي اني اطلع من هنا
وانتم عارفين عشر كلمات اشاريه وارجو من
الجميع ان يطبق معي دون حياه لا تخجل
بدايتك تتعلم اي لغه عدم الخجل فارجو
طبقوا معي البدايه هي التحيه لما تيجي
تسلم على اصم ما تمد يدك على طول وهو مو
منتبه حتسوي له تحيه بهذه الطريقه ارجو من
الجميع يطبق دون حيا السلام عليكم ثم تمد
اييدك وتسلم عليه وتصافحه هذه السلام مثل
ما احنا نستخدمها من بعيد السلام عليكم
كيف الحال كيف الحال صيغه سؤال فلذلك لازم
ان يكون جسدك يحاكي صيغه الاستفهام كيف
الحال كيف الحال كيف الحال الحمد لله تبي
تجاوب عليه تقول الحمد لله ترفع ايديك
تقول الحمد لله الحمد لله بهذه الطريقه
الحمد لله الاسم الاسم الاصبع السبابه
دائما احنا الباج او التاج بالنسبه
للموظفين والعساكر يحطون اساميهم هنا فب
باصبعك السبابه اسم فتقول انا اسمي سهله
لغه الاشاره لكن تحتاج الى تركيز شوي وراح
تبدع فيها انت اسمك في الاصبع انا ما اشوف
احد يطبق انا اسمي طبق معي اسمي وانت اسمك
هذه اشاره الاسم العمر ماخوذ من السن فنفس
الاصبع تحطه على سنك السن مرتين سن سن انا
سني او عمري وانت عمرك العمل ماخوذ من هذه
الطريق قبضه يد ثابته وقبضه يد متحركه
لداخل الجسم عمل عمل انا عندي عمل وهذه
اشاره موظف كذلك نفس الاشاره الطالب يختلف
كتاب
طالب طالب هذه اشاره طالب
طالب طالب طيب
العاطل موظف لكن باضافه النفي
موظف غير موظف غير موظف متزوج عقد قران
بين اثنين وبالتالي عقد بهذه الطريقه
متزوج متزوج اصبعين تعكف على بعض لا
تقولون كذا هذه معناته السياره تسحب سياره
ثانيه
لا تفرطوا ترى في دقه في اداء الاشاره هذه
متزوج متزوج جيد غير متزوج او اعزب متزوج
ايش غير
متزوج هل لغه الاشاره واحده في العالم هذا
سؤال دائما يورد والله يقوللك انا اعرف
لغه الاشاره السعوديه وبالتالي اقدر
استخدمها في كل العالم لغه الاشاره تتاثر
بمؤثر واحد والبيئه عندنا احنا البيئه
ثقاف البيئه الدينيه البيئه الاجتماعيه
عندنا شماغ الاحمر شماغ الاحمر لكنه غير
موجود وغير مستخدم وليس من بيئه مثلا
اوروبا بالتالي هذه الاشاره غير متدارك
عندهم من هنا اقول ان لغه الاشاره مختلفه
من منطقه الى منطقه كل ما اختلفت البيئه
كل ما اختلفت لغه الاشاره عندنا اكثر من
300 لغه اشاره في العالم
معتمده عودا على قصهه مع
عائلتي انا اصبحت هذه هذا الموضوع اصبح
قضيه بالنسبه لي وبديت بناه واطرق كل
الابواب التي اتمنى انها تعالج هذه القضيه
ثم مارست لغه الاشاره كمترجم وصلت ى الحمد
لله من ان اصبحت اول مترجم رسمي في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذا المسمى
الوظيفي واول خبير لغه اشاره وقضايا الصم
تبع الاتحاد العربي للهيئات العامله لد
لدى الصم وبدات اقطع مشواري وما زلت يرى
البعض اني وصلت الى قمه في في هذا المجال
حيث كنت اكثر مؤثر او اكثر متر جمين
تاثيرا بالنسبه للفئه لكن ما زلت ارى نفسي
في بدايه الطريق ما دام هناك صعوبات
يواجهها
الصم الصور الموجوده عندكم هنا نفذت ان
مجموعه من الصم القاموس السعودي الاول قبل
اربع سنوات وفاز بجائزه الملك خالد قله
الحمد
لمنه
شكرا ثم العام الماضي فزت بجائزه الاميره
صيته بنت عبد العزيز رحمه الله لاكثر
المترجمين ارشاده بلغه الاشاره هذه الصوره
الثانيه تجمعني ب سابقا كان معالي وزير
الشؤون الاجتماعيه ثم كان الشرف لي ان
اكلف بترجمه اعلان الرؤيه السعوديه 20 30
وله الحمد
له اعتاد الناس ان يراني دائما مكان
الشباب اني على الصامت في التلفزيون
تشوفوني تحت ومسيرتي في التلفاز 16 سنه
وفي البعض المناسبات الخاصه مثلا في مؤسسه
مسك وغير وترجم لكن المره اقف بين ايديكم
حتى اعطيكم هذا هذه القصه التي اعيشها بين
المعاناه والمتعه هناك جانب ممتع انا
ذكرته انه لغه الاشاره ملهمه وممتعه لغه
الاشاره ببساطه والله ممتعه انا اجد ساعات
اتكلم مع الصم ما امل لانها تحاكي لغه
وتجيب لك وصف يعني ممتع لكن هناك جانب
مظلم اعطيكم واحده من الجوانب الممتعه لما
اقول لك مثلا واحد في خندق قتال انه قاعد
في الخندق وقاعد يناظر اذا في واحد من
العدو جاي ولا لا شوفوا كيف استخدام لغه
الجسد زين وملامح الوجه والتعبيري ناظر
انه في واحد يمر من الاعداء بينما لما هذا
ممتع نجلس بالساعات لكن هناك قضيه احنا
نعيشها اليوم قضيه الصم في المستشفيات
يواجهون تحدي مره كبير لما يروح المستشفى
انا واحده من الحالات او كثير من الحالات
اللي يعيش معها واحد يكلمني الساعه ث
فيديو يقول انا في سرير في سرير الطوارئ
دخلوني عمليات ماني عارف ش اسوي تخيلوا
وصلنا للحد بديت اترجم له صار عنده التهاب
شديد في الزائده الدوديه ويبغى يسوي عمليه
واحده من القصص واحد من الصم كان يصاب
بفشل كلوي لانه راح اربع مرات المستشفى
الدكتور مو عارف ياخذ التاريخ المرضي
بالنسبه له ف لما رحت مع ترجمت له صار
عنده شبه انسداد في الحوالب وبالتالي لو
جلس تاخر اصيب بفشل كلوي عندي من الجماعه
اثنين توفوا بمضاعفات بالفشل الكلوي لسبب
عدم وجود وقايه وتوعيه كافيه من
الصم يعيش الصم اليوم معاناه حقيقيه لدى
الجهات الحكوميه ولدى كثير من الجهات
الرسميه يعني واحده من التحديات البنوك
واحده من التحديات كذلك عندنا اللي هم
الجهات القضائيه لما يدخل الاصم في قضايا
من الصم كانوا دخلنا فيها كاد ان يحكم على
الاصم لانه ما كان مفهوم نقل المعلومه
بالشكل الصحيح ما بينه وبين القاضي عدد
قله عدد المترجمين قابلوا عدد من من
الضحايا من الصوم بالتالي من هنا من هذا
المنبر اتمنى انه يتبنى هذه القضيه لحلها
باذن الله تعالى وان يكون هناك غدا اتمنى
ان ارى هناك ممثلين حتى لمسلسل او اطباء
او قضاه او حتى وكلاء وزارات متقنين لهذه
اللغه لو بابجد التواصل وانا على استعداد
للتعاون مع جميع اطياف المجتمع وشرائحه
ومسؤوليه لحل هذه القضيه لانها القضيه
الام بالنس لي وهي بالنسبه لي حياه او موت
ان هذه القضيه لابد ان
تعالج باقي 30 ثانيه هذا الكود اذا قدرتوا
تصورون راح يوصلكم على قناتي في اليوتيوب
فيها بالتعاون مع تيدكس اهم 30 مصطلح
اشاري للتواصل يعطيك مفاتيح للتواصل مع
الاصم التحيه السلام السؤال عن الحال
العمر العمل يعني
بعض المصطلحات المهمه في التعامل مع الاصم
وارجو ان اكون ما اطلت عليكم والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وبركاته